this whole thing with dubai right let me
dubai emirates suspends flights to
several us destinations on 5g concerns
uh this is a reuters story the move is
due to operational concerns associated
with the planned development of 5g
mobile network services in the us the
company said that it the destinations
include boston chicago dallas fort worth
houston miami newark orlando san
francisco and seattle we are working
closely with aircraft manufacturers and
their relevant authorities to alleviate
operational concerns and we hope to
resume our u.s services as soon as
possible the carrier said the white
house said earlier on tuesday that it
wants to reach a solution on 5g
development that protects air safety
while minimizing uh disruption to air
travel how much of this really is 5g how
much of it is protecting a different
messaging that's happening behind closed
doors with traveling with vaccination
cards how much of it is you know
what do you think the story lies john
i'm going to go to you first
i don't i can't answer any of those
questions is it's fear porn again it's
y2k the planes are going to crash but
isn't 5g already in use yeah
and the airlines are crashing
major u.s airlines have already told the
faa no
they told them no about what
about
shutting down yeah right exactly
meaning what though they're going to
shut down flights
they're not going to they're no the
america the american big american
airlines the faa was like we got to
figure this 5g thing out and it's you
know it's scrambling it's not safe you'd
be in the sky and american airlines were
like not american airlines itself but
big american airline companies i got you
no i got you played this video because
you know
tyler's got this video that he wants to
show with 5g again folks this is just a
video i don't want you to lose your mind
it's just a video title found go ahead
so and then the caption here is the faa
published 1400 plus notices to airmen
about 5g and international airlines they
were canceling flights they warned
pilots not to use their radio altimeter
at more than 80 airports in the us it
just drives the gauges wild
yeah i mean it scrambles them but you're
assuming the pilot can't fly the plane
and that they won't adjust to this well
he can't fly the plane if he doesn't
have his gauges and he doesn't know
where he's at and his altitude and
whether he's not if he's straight and
level if he's in a bank etc etc etc then
why haven't we seen planes come down
yeah how do i know that's just not a
faulty radar that's just something that
how do i know that's why
you're right david that's why i said you
know this is just a video that tyler
found online that's showing that
uh let me throw some stats your way
because 20 major air um airports have
basically created a buffer zone all the
major airports in uh new york la miami
orlando
uh dfw and dallas um seattle philly i
mean there's 20 airports that said you
cannot have 5g within uh two miles of
our airport okay and
i'm not the 5g expert however they're
going to stop it
i don't know but you can't have towers
you'll restrict yeah you'll be
restricted exactly but basically
where it comes into play is not so much
when they're flying around the sky and
they're you know 10 miles up in the air
it's regarding the landings it's when
they're closer within a thousand feet
of the tower is what they're worried
about and then the airlines of the pilot
unions which are not exactly always
seeing eye to eye they're actually
locked up on this they're on the same
page they're basically in a 100
agreement that this is basically
um something that they need to be very
weary of because essentially this comes
down to safety yeah over speed i mean
what's the point of 5g it's basically
these
you know cell phone companies are
basically putting up 5g so you can
download your porn even quicker or
communicate even quicker not you john
obviously not you but it's safe to your
speed and
you know i think right now we're doing
pretty good with the 4g with the speed
uh the 5g is going to make it 10 times
100 times faster but
look we've got a pretty good remember
the happy medium of protecting the
airspace in the immediate vicinity of
the airport then okay
yeah well we've got a very good record
of safety in on our air i don't think
any major u.s airline has crashed in the
last decade even longer u.s airlines
domestically 100
so safety is a major concern i mean
people get scared if there's you know
some turbulence on a plane now if
there's a plane that flies off the
runway god forbid the hudson type things
happens again
you know so it's a it's a safety thing
i'm not the 5g expert but basically when
you see the airlines and the pilot
unions basically on the same page that
should be a telltale sign that they're
very concerned about this and then
there's and then we've found a solution
what's the solution
the buffer zone yeah okay
i mean i i've had 5g on my phone all
over the country for the past few months
i i looked down and i'm like i'm i'm on
5g right now okay do you have strong
feelings about this 5g pet but i doubt i
bet when i'm close to the airport this
afternoon when i'm heading back to dfw
that the 5g disappears i i don't know
you go to these doctors and they say
do you have a lot of headaches i do do
you wear the your uh uh apple uh or what
are you calling your earbuds like i do
well we're getting a lot of people that
are coming here saying they get a lot of
headaches from wearing that you may want
to stop wearing that because of you know
whatever radiation they're talking i'm
like okay is there a hundred percent
there i don't know they've been talking
about stuff like this for a long time
they would talk about if you live near
towers cancer increases i mean
the it has it never has proven
that's that's what you said earlier so
um i think we got to get a good
investigative journalist i think we know
one that can go out there to these plays
too much volleyball it's not gonna
happen
he plays way too much volleyball it's
problematic so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]